Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and we're going to be doing a series of three videos on the cell
Dager response. The cell danger response. This is a response that takes place in
Your cells from a cellular level
In a protective measure, but sometimes these survival mechanisms of our cells
Can hurt us and that's what we're going to discuss
In this series. So we have a survival mechanisms that take place in the cell when we experience different traumas
Even emotional trauma affects ourselves, but mainly physical trauma
Biological trauma. So physical trauma would be like damage to like a bruise or an injury. That's a physical trauma
There's a protective measure that takes place in order to prevent cell
more cell death and more cell damage
Biological trauma would be in the classification of an infection of some kind
So when we have a bio-toxin which means a livid organism like a pathogen, so a bacterial infection, a Lyme disease infection or a
virus is a biological trauma and a chemical trauma is an exposure to some sort of chemical like a heavy metal
toxicity or a pesticide toxicity and these things are taking place all the time
We are bruising ourselves all the time. You're bumpy yourself all the time
biological traumas are extremely
common
Due to just exposure to viruses and exposures to different bacteria and your body has to respond to these and
Chemical traumas are just becoming more and more prevalent. There are more and more chemicals on the market on a daily basis
And these chemicals are affecting or we should say our body has to respond to
These chemicals in a way that's going to protect ourselves. So constant exposure to these chemicals
either via
constant exposure meaning that I'm that I'm
Putting more in my body on a daily basis or my body's inability to detox these chemicals
So I'm having constant exposure is
Causing this cell danger response that is supposed to take place over a matter of minutes over a matter of days
To be a constant response that's taking place on a cellular basis. So that's where we see
Problems. That's really what we're going to be talking about
So this cell danger response that is supposed to be a protective measure for a matter of minutes a matter of hours or a matter of days
It's becoming a chronic
Cellular condition and it's changing in the way by cells work and that's what can lead to
So much ill health you could say this is what leads to cancer
This is what leads to someone having a more chronic addition the difference with somebody who gets Lyme disease and
It is recovers just fine after taking some antibiotics and three months later
Doesn't even remember the incident and someone who gets Lyme disease and
Is suffering 10 years later with that from that same exposure 10 years ago or someone who is diagnosed with cancer and
Doesn't know where it came from
Well, we have to look back over time and you see this person has been in a chronic cell danger response for some time
So understand what a cell danger response is
In the case of it infection in this example you have different
Signally that takes place in the cell to protect the cell from
Be damaged by that virus. So a virus or a bacterial infection
Will eventually could kill the cell and if you kill enough cells you damaged the tissue you damaged the tissue you damaged the organ
You damaged the organ because death of the organism. That's us
So our body responds to protect itself and
That is great for that period of time to make those changes that we're going to see as we go through these slides
But when we get stuck in that situation, that's what leads to even greater ill health
So when this persists the cell danger response persists
Abnormally because that's not normal. This is supposed to be a short term response to a short term problem, but when we have a log term
Irritation something that's stimulating this cell danger response, then we are going to see the issues
so
What are the things that takes place as we see when we look at a
Persons health picture like this is one test that we do on all our patients is
We look at the balance between their sympathetic and their parasympathetic nervous system
And would you see this sympathetic in the case of this picture right here at that number five?
It's shown in a different graph at number four there and the raw data is at number one
But at number five there
This is the balance between the sympathetic in this blue bar graph here
Sympathetic is on the left of the parasympathetic is on the right when we're stuck in a sympathetic response
We are stuck in this this that is a sign that we're in the immediate
Cell danger response we have the sympathetic response of our nervous system in order to protect the cells in order to protect our body
Which is necessary for the time but when we're stuck in that situation over time
Then we'd see a lot of damage and eventually what we see a
Test like this where we're measuring the balance read sympathetic and parasympathetic we see both of those sympathetic and parasympathetic
Both high both of those bar those were you see on this the
Blue bar graph or sympathetic is in the high range and the blue bar graph for the parasympathetic is in
the low range
Over a long period of time you'll see both the sympathetic and the parasympathetic at the very high range in many times my patients are
Camped out. They're both off the graph and that is because the
Chrotic inflammation is so great. It's affecting the brain so my front to low was not able to communicate to the
Archaeocortex the midbrain where the parasympathetics and the sympathetic are housed so the lack of inhibition that lack of
Call be that lack of regulation to the
Autonomic nervous system is in balance so understand take a step back your sympathetic and your parasympathetic nervous system are part of your
Autonomic think automatic nervous system that is supposed to control
Basically your organ function your cellular function and it is it is a neurological control not a chemical control
So when our nervous system senses any sort of danger will go into a sympathetic response and a whole bunch of different chemical things
Take place different
Hormonal changes take place in order for us to overcome that stress or or that injury
But when we're living in that when that becomes a part of us when we have a chronic
Bio-toxin when we have a chronic injury and we even see this with people
This is the exact same response the cell day your response happens with people that over exercise
You're getting constant damage constant dish tissue damage you might be getting very buffeted shape
But you're damaging your cells at a cellular
Basis and I get cancer patients that call me
Quite often I can't figure out what's wrong with me. I'm the pity me of shape. I've been teaching yoga classes and and
And health classes for years. I've been in the best the best condition. I've ever been in life
What's wrong with my body? You have to look at this picture are you stuck in a cell day?
Your response and have you been for the last 10 years and that's what's leading to your current diagnosis so
This is a very important picture your cell day your response again is supposed to be a temporary response to deal with a stressor in your life and
That what's that stressor decreases then are that cell day your response turns off and when that turns off our body goes back into
homeostasis goes back into a balance between the autonomics a balance between
the hormonal
function
The chemical function that's taking place and that cell day your response turns off
So we don't want to live there that causes all sorts of problems that will see changes from a
Chemical response as well. So other tests that we want to run our genetic tests. That's super important
We're gonna talk a lot about that
and and
Other biological chemical tests that tell us byproducts of how those how your genes are functioning and we can see
Upregulations the down regulations of genes even if there are not gene defects that could tell us the response that my body is in
Due to its current function
So again an infection a toxicity a chronic
Overexercising a chronic injury is gonna change the
Electron balance change the chemical balance intra extra cellular as as
Our body is is trying to fight this disease
It changes the way our cells function on the inside the mitochondria change
And all sorts of different things take place and this is just one example of what takes place in the mitochondria
It shuts down oxygen
increases redox
oxidation in the cells
And your your cells don't have the building blocks to continue to function a Tp function decreases
and we end up with reactive oxygen species and
We're gonna see what takes place especially this even is even accelerated if we have specific genetic defects and
These damages could be irreversible
Maybe it could cause the cell to start acting like a cancer cell in a rapid replication
This is what could the damage the DNA and said this person into
Cancer condition so it becomes very serious so at the end of this
Set of arrows it says once the danger is eradicated a normalcy is
Supposed to resume in the cycle in the circle reviews reverses
But the problem is is that when the danger doesn't go away
When we have a chronic subclinical infection
So this is the worst lot of you are saying. I don't have any chronic infection
What we're really speaking about is not a chronic infection that most people will recognize
For instance heart disease the number one cause of heart disease is proxieditrate formation
Well, what causes that typically a chronic
Micotoxid or chronic H. Pylori infection that the person never ever knew that they had and
That up-regulates nitric oxide production and you complicate issues with this person having SODG defects
They have decreased
Ability to get rid of reactive oxygen species that combines with
excess nitric oxide because of a chronic infection causing a
Highly wrapped up proxieditrate formation. What's proxieditrate?
It's a very damaging chemical to your endothelial cells. What are they?
They're the cells that lie your arteries and when you damage the cells that lie your arteries
You're going to have arterial
sclerosis you're going to have all the coronary heart diseases if it's in your heart you're going to have plackied and
cholesterol tries to
Cover that wound and protect that plaque and the
Advertising agencies of the pharmaceuticals have blamed the whole problem on cholesterol
So we'll give you lipitor to decrease the cholesterol that doesn't decrease the placky that may decrease the placky
But it doesn't decrease the bulging the inflammation that's taking place in the endothelial cells
Which is really the cause of the coronary heart disease and?
The coronary heart disease is the number one cause of death in the United States right now
proxieditrate
Effects the endothelial cells greatly proxieditrate also affects the cells themselves not just the endothelial cells the cells that lie in the arteries
but other cells in the in the body and increase
Oxidation
Species and increase cancer rates so this is a bad guy here
And we got to deal with this and these are things that you can deal with and you can take proactive
Approaches, so this is why I'm so into having everybody get their 23 be done and get a genetic test done because at least you can see do I have
um defects on my NOS genes there that will wrap up my dietary coccyte so you can have this even without having an infection
And do I have defects on my SOD genes these are things these two are very
um, you can say
Repairable but supportable you can support those defects and decrease your risk of heart disease and cancer
Log before you have a diagnosis
So what do you do is this hopeless? Oh my gosh, this is horrible. I got the cell data response. I'm constantly living in stress
I know this is going on at me. I constantly I've had live disease for 10 years
I feel awful and maybe this is the cause of my sickness etc
Well, go back to what we do and I've been preaching on this for 30 years. You have to identify the causes
Do you have genetic defects? Do I have a chronic infection?
Do I have um, you know, chronic stress at my life do I have, you know, go on and on? There's
Thousand different possibilities here. You have to support the pathways
So we have to look at this genetic pathways that are going bad and what are we going to do about them?
Learn more about this go to our website
Connors, Glitter, it's right there in the quarter go to the genetic testing tab
You'll see a bunch of videos similar to this that go over the genetic testing
That tell you how to get a genetic test and then how to schedule an appointment to go over your genetic test
And it can be extremely revealing. I have never once had a person
Uh, have me go over their genetic test to go. I wish I didn't spend the money on this
Almost everybody says this is the best money I've ever spent
Because it could literally save your life and it's really not even that expensive. So
Make sure you do that
And then that gives you the ability to heal and allow yourself time to heal. So
Hope this video was helpful. I have at least two more of this subject coming up
So make sure you catch those as well. Thank you again. Have a great day